في السودان يدخل الذهب معتركه الصراع
الدائر حاليا مرتفعا الى اعلى اعلى
مستوياته منذ سنوات المعدن النفيس الذي
يعد اهم
او ارض السودانيه اصبح ملاذا امنا لمن
يريدون او يريد ان يدخر ثروته ارتفاع
اسعار الذهب اصبح يهدد النساء اللواتي
يرغبن في شرائه للتزين خصوصا مع وصول
ليجرام الواحد منه لاكثر من 33 الف جنيه
سوداني ومع ازمه ذهب السوداني يخشى الناس
من تفاقم اسعاره ليس في بلاده فحسب ولكن
في العالم اجمع فلماذا تمثل السودان
وذهبها بالنسبه او ماذا تمثل لهم
للاقتصاد العالمي تحديدا
سنعرف الاجابه مع لميس
يعد الذهب احد اهم الثروات القوميه في
السودان وتصنف السودان في المرتبه الثالثه
عشر عالميا بانتاج المعدن الاصفر السودان
تحتل ايضا المركز الثالث في افريقيا كاحد
اهم دول القاره انتاجا للمعدن النفيس كذلك
يصل احتياط السودان من الذهب الى نحو 1550
طنا فيما تشكل صدراتها 45% من الصادرات
الاجماليه وينتج السودان حاليا نحو من 95
الى 100 طن سنويا ويعد الذهب السوداني احد
اكثر انواع الذهب تركيزا في العالم وتنتشر
منجم الذهب في مناطق متفرقه من السودان في
سحاره وجبال شرق نهر النيل وفي محاذاه
البحر الاحمر واعلى سلسله جبال البحر
الاحمر في شرق السودان وايضا في مناطق
جبال النوبه ومنطقه كوردوف كردفان شديده
الفقر وتنتشر فيها الحروب والمجاعات
والصراعات
مشاهدينا من عمان الخبير الاقتصادي عامر
الشوبكي اهلا بك استاذ عامر معنا
صباح النور اهلا وسهلا طيب استاذ عامر
الان ومع يعني الاوضاع في السودان وكون
السودان ارض غنيه جدا بالمعادن بشكل عام
والذهب المعدن النفيس ايضا بشكل خاص هل ما
الذي يعني ما هي التداعيات التي ستكون على
سوق الذهب العالمي على اسعار الذهب مع هذه
الازمه في السودان هل سيكون لها وقع واثر
كبير
صباح الخير الراويه وعادل والمشاهدين
السودان دوله مهمه في انتاج الذهب يعني
على صعيد الاحصاءات الرسميه هو الثالث في
افريقيا والخامس عشر عالميا لكن اعتقد
بانه مرتبه اعلى من هذا هنالك الكثير من
الذهب يصدر من السودان ايضا بطرق رسميه
لذلك اعتقد بان
الاربعين طن التي يعلن عنها من انتاج
الذهب في السودان هي اعلى من ذلك تصل الى
اكثر من مئه طن سنويا من الذهب واعتقد ان
الرقم ايضا يعني مرافق لعمليات انتاج
الذهب في السودان هنالك يعني مناجم معروفه
رسميه وهنالك ايضا ما يسمى في السودان
ابار يعني ذهب وتنتج من الافراد بملكيات
خاصه ايضا هذه بشكل غير رسمي وايضا حتى من
المناجم الرسميه هنالك انتاج ذهب بشكل غير
رسمي من السودان يتم تهريبه للخارج
عالميا الان حسب الاوضاع السياسيه الصعبه
المعقده في السودان بالتاكيد سيكون انخفاض
في انتاج الذهب وهذا
سيخفض المعروض سواء اقليميا او حتى داخليه
السودان او حتى عربيا عندما نعلم بانه
يعني دوله عربيه تشتري مثلا معظم انتاج
السودان مثلا في النصف الاول من العام
الماضي فهذا يؤثر على المعروض من الذهب في
هذه الدول عاده الاسباب الدوليه نعم عامر
انا انا يهمني جيب الرجل اللي راح يصاب
بفقر دم بسبب غلاء وارتفاع اسعار الذهب
حينما يشتري لزوجته او يهديه الى متى
سيستمر الذهب بهذا الارتفاع وهل هو بالفعل
ملاذ امن اليوم انه نحطه اموالنا في الذهب
ما نروح الاسهم ما نروح قطع اخر
نعم عادل كلامك مزبوط الان الله يعيني
المتزوجين في الايام الحاليه لارتفاع
اسعار الذهب هي اسعار تاريخيه غير مسبوقه
يعني
اوقيه الذهب اكثر من
2000 دولار وهذا هذا هذا الرقم مرتفع جدا
وربما من الاسعار الاعلى تاريخيا في اسعار
الذهب الان ننتظر ايضا ارتفاعات اخرى حسب
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه مؤثرات كثيره على
اسعار الذهب اذا ما يعني توقعنا اسعار
الذهب في المستقبل القريب او المتوسط
هنالك تاثيرات معدلات التضخم رفع اسعار
الفائده هي يعني للغايه تؤثر على اسعار
الذهب ايضا محليا اسعار الصرف في بعض
الدول تؤثر على اسعار الذهب فترى انه
اسعار الذهب العالميه لا تنعكس بشكل كامل
على مثلا بلد معين لانه سعر الصرف بشكل
عام ارتفاع باسعار نعم فبالتالي على الاقل
انه هذا مش الوقت المناسب والامثل انه
تشتروا ذهب بس ممكن يشتروا اشياء معاد ن
اخرى وهذا هو السؤال
الفضه ممكن يكون
يعني طريقه اخرى او ملاذقه من اخر او اي
معادن اخرى نفيسه ممكن انه تحل محل الذهب
في الفتره اللي اسعاره فيها كتير عاليه
بالنسبه للنساء كمان
نعم نعم راويه للنساء هو زينه وخزينه زي
ما بحكواها يعني هو للامان المستقبلي
للتخزين وايضا للزينه وهي موروث شعبي عند
النساء خاصه في المنطقه العربيه
وجزء من
يعني نعم غالي كثير لكن يعني ما زال في
اقبال عليه الفضه ربما يكون خيار يعني
للطبقه الاقل للفقراء ربما ملاد الفقراء
نستطيع ان نسميه نوعا ما لكن اعتقد بانه
الذهب اكثر رواجا واكثر استخداما واكثر
قيمه حتى اذا ما كان للخزين او للاستثمار
لبعض الفئات فلذلك اعتقد بانه اللجوء
للذهب نوعا ما اقل بكثير من اللجوء اللجوء
الى الفضه اقل بكثير من نجوم من الذهب
شكرا جزيلا للخبير الاقتصادي عامر الشوبكي
كنت معنا من عمان يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا
جزيلا لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائ قيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات